visual intelligence is the concept that
we see more than we can process and it's
the idea of thinking about what we see
taking in the information and what do we
really need to live our lives more
purposefully and do our jobs more
effectively I work across the
professional spectrum so I work with
police officers and intelligence
analysts and doctors and nurses and
librarians but what's interesting for me
is that the forays are applicable to all
of them and what they are is any new
situation any new problem and a new
client any new transaction any new
environment that you're in you practice
forays the first one is you assess your
situation what do I have in front of me
what information is here I want people
to go beyond the four corners of what
they think they see so this is what's in
front of me this is where I am
ask someone yes this is my situation
here's where I am this is what I see is
there something here I might be missing
because by asking someone else we
realize that no two people see anything
the same way so of course that doesn't
work all the time but if you're in an
office situation if you're in a medical
situation and you have the opportunity
to collaborate you'll get the biggest
picture of your assessment if you ask
other people what they see as well the
second step is to analyze the
information that's where you break it
down and you say what's important what
do I need to prioritize what's most
important and what don't I really have
to worry about at all I find that when
you make a mental list in your head okay
here's my situation and you divide it
into two categories information I need
information I might need an information
I definitely don't need and for the
information that you definitely don't
need put it away because our brains are
so cluttered with so much information
that if you can from the outset get rid
of some information do it but keep that
middle category information that you
might need because you might not have
you might be have to draw on it when you
don't realize that it's important it
could become more important as the
process goes on and then the third a I
think is actually the most important
it's how you articulate what you observe
whether you send an email whether you
pick up the phone whether you tell a
colleague whether you write it down the
idea of putting into words what your
observations are is the most important
because I tell all my groups I don't
know why this is but something gets lost
from here to here to here our brains and
our eyes see something but when it comes
to articulating those observations
whether it's poor choice of words or an
inability to communicate effectively
there's a real loss that I'm trying to
redress I ask people to be mindful of
every word every word counts and an
example that I can give you that I give
in the book was the investigation of the
murder of Chandra Levy in Washington DC
back in 2001 when the instruction was
given to look for her body the
instruction was to look 100 or 100 yards
from every trail in the park where she
disappeared but when the instruction was
repeated they said look a hundred yards
from every road in the park now the
change of one word from trail to road
changed the whole scope of the
investigation so in that third day in
that articulating what you observe I
asked people be mindful of every word
because someone is listening and every
word counts and the fourth a is after
you've assessed analyzed and articulated
what it is that you observe you adapt
your behavior or you make a decision or
as I like to say you act you you take
all that information then you make a
judgment call based on those three other
elements I want people to act according
to their observations so if you're ever
questioned about why you made a certain
decision why did you take a certain Road
why did you solve the problem this way
you're able to go back to the other A's
and say well I thought the situation was
this this was the information I thought
was important I perceive this therefore
I made this decision give yourself the
tools to back up the decisions you make
so that when you're questioned about
your decisions you have all the
information you need to make a
thoughtful
full and objective assessment of why you
made the decision